Hi, I'm James.
I'm here to talk to you about breaking changes.
To provide a bit of context and introduce
myself, I am the creator of and maintainer
of the this set of MPM packages that provide
WebSocket messaging, various layers of that
protocol.
They're widely used by different projects.
They generate about eight million downloads
a week between them, and I've been maintaining
these pretty much since Node was released,
so since early 2010.
So this is a reflection of my experience as
an open-source maintainer of seeing things
change over time, and what the effects of
that are.
An additional bit of context.
This talk should not be construed as a complaint
about how things work.
We should be really grateful for all the software
that we get for free that lets us do loads
of amazing stuff.
I'm trying to reflect on again my own experience
rather than bashing anybody else and saying
you're doing this wrong.
It's how can we reflect and improve what we
are doing?
Okay, so, with that out of the way, what do
we mean by "breaking"?
Consider this module at the top that has a
method called "get", and it takes a URL and
makes an HTTP request of the URL and invokes
a callback with a status code which I've hard-coded
here as a number.
Let's say we change that number 404 and replace
it with the string 404.
Do we think that is breaking change or not?
To answer that, we have to look at some use
cases.
If something is calling this function, and
it's using the weaker quality operator to
compare the numbers, that will keep working,
because, in JavaScript, a number is week weakly
equal to its string representation.
However, if we're using stricter quality,
this code will now break because numbers and
strings are never strictly equal to each other,
so, if we have this code, we consider the
change to the HTTP module to have broken our
programme.
Another example: this module contains a method
that takes the name of a table and it runs
a query to count the number of records in
that table, and then it invokes your callback
with the count which again I've hard-coded,
and in the something about this module.
This is structural usual identical to the
other module that I just showed you.
All I've done is replace some of the names.
The actual programmatic structure in terms
of what the compiler cares about is the same
as the HTTP module, so, if we believe that
that breaking change compatibility is purely
a function of the source code itself, then
we have to give the same answer for the HTTP
module and this one.
Let's look at some use cases.
So, say somebody is counting the number of
records in tables and then subtracting them,
for example, to work out the number of remaining
tickets left for a conference, now, in JavaScript,
the subtraction operator coerces strings to
number so you get arithmetic sub extraction
and the same result you had before.
If you're adding them together, the plus operator
has an overloaded meeting, performing numbers
and concatenate strings together.
If something was a number and now a string,
we get the string concatenation of those two
values, so this value no longer — programme
does the same thing, and the author of this
programme would consider it broken by the
changes made.
So, yeah, we would have to make an explicit
change here to account for the fact that the
database module has changed how it represents
the results to us by explicitly converting
the strings back to numbers again.
So, what we've seen here is that the meaning
of values in programmes is not, like, fully
contained within themselves.
It is not to do with what their type is, like
a number can be used for several different
purposes, it depends how you're using it that
determines whether changing it would be a
problem.
So, what we've seen is that, rather than just
beak a number, like something having one type,
it actually has a set of characteristic traits.
A Java programmer might call these "interfacers".
Haskell users might call them type classes,
but the idea is that a value of a certain
type can be used for different operations,
and it's which of those operations that you're
using which determines their true meaning.
So we've seen a couple of these already, like
a number might be used for its identity, like
an HTTP status code is not like an arithmetic
number, it's a machine-readable label for
something.
But numbers also have arithmetic properties.
You might want to do maths with them, addition
and subtraction, and so on.
So that is a little bit of an example of why
the complexity even exists in very simple
values like numbers.
What about objects?
What happens when we change the interfaces
to those?
Let's say we have a function that returns
an object that convince some information about
— that returns some information about the
returns of the conference, in fact, this talk
in this conference.
It contains a title, date, and a presenter,
all of which are strings.
Now, adding a new field to this object is
probably not a problem.
Any programme that is using this will probably
just ignore the fact that the new field exists,
right?
It won't be relying on it, so this object
gaping a few field won't disrupt any existing
code.
However, if we remove a field, like the title
object — sorry, the title property — some
code that is using this function will now
probably break, so, for example, if we are
calling get hook info and putting the title
attribute of the result into a string, we
will now get a string containing undefined,
and this is a case where JavaScript doesn't
alert you to the fact that it has made a mistake.
You don't get an error if you access an attribute
that doesn't exist, you get the value undefined,
and that shows up in the spring.
The programme hasn't broken in the sense that
it is crashing, but it is clearly not doing
what was intended.
A user will notice that something weird has
happened here.
Likewise, changing the types of existing fields
is likely to break existing programmes.
So, for example, if we were calling get hook
info and then split the date field on dashes
to break the date into its component parts,
that will no longer work because a date object
doesn't have a split method.
So, in broad terms, adding new fields to an
object is fine.
The existing callers will just ignore that
new field.
Removing a field might break things as we've
seen, and JavaScript won't alert you to that
problem.
And changing the type of existing fields can
also break things.
Sometimes, you will get an error because you're
using a method that doesn't exist, but sometimes,
the programme will silently do the wrong thing.
But it's not quite as simple as that.
JavaScript being a small language has overloaded
the few abstractions that it has with several
different meanings.
There are multiple different ideas and computation
that is are overloaded on to the same thing
in JavaScript, and, one of those things is
object.
We use object to represent the computational
idea of maps, of records, of object-orientated
style objects, and several other things, so
what do these terms mean?
We are using this one thing object for a lot
of different functions.
We need to think about the different ways
in which it's used.
So a map is an open-ended collection of key
value pairs and, typically, the programme
doesn't care about what specific keys are
in the object, it is just data, and it gets
processed, like whatever is there is processed.
Typically, if your programme is iterating
over an object and owing what is — and programming
what it contains, it uses a map.
A record is a fixed set of known fields where
the field can have different types and the
programme usually cares about specific fields
within an object, so the proxy pass to react
component are a good example of this.
You don't just iterate over them and do the
same thing over the fields, you normally pick
out the specific fields and put them in specific
places in your UI.
An object-orientated programming kind of object
is bit like an extension of a record.
It is a computational value that combines
state with behaviour, so it's like a record
where some of the fields are functions that
access the record's other data fields.
So the image value that I used in the previous
example here is a good example of that, that
image.url bit comes from a class that takes
a name, and it has a method that those how
to calculate the URL for the particular size
of an image.
Typically, adding new methods to an OAP style
object is fine which enables polymorphism,
which means that one function can work with
lots of different kind of objects as long
as they have a method in common.
Its rivel in JavaScript is an example of this
adding now fields to other things like records
can cause problems.
So, for example, if you add a field to your
web pack could be config that it doesn't recognise,
you would get an error.
It checks everything that your object includes,
and, if it don't recognise it, it gets an
error.
The kind of programme that web pack is, it
indicates an error on the part of the user
if it includes data that should not be there
— it usually indicates a typo, or a field
that is no longer supported if you've upgraded
from 3 to 4.
So it's not always the case that adding new
fields to something keeps your programme working.
In some cases, it will break them, and that's
done for ergonomic reasons to help the user
use the programme correctly.
Likewise, if you're inserting something in
a database, if you trying to I to save an
object to a table, should that be silently
ignored if it doesn't have a property?
Should that be silently ignored?
ORMs typically include explicit instructions
for these properties get saved to the database
and these don't and the user has to decide
which things belong in which category.
So that's a little bit about — we've seen
how primitive values like numbers can contain
quite a lot of complexity, and, likewise,
something like object can take on a lot of
different computational meanings, and so changing
it has different effects in different circumstances.
But another thing that causes programmes to
break is just the concepts we are expressing
are too complicated.
One example of this was the recent proposal
to add the flat method to the array prototype,
and a lot of people petitioned TC39 not to
do this because it would conflict with another
implementation already out in the wild.
Why would this be a problem?
It's partly for sort of logistical reasons,
like, TC39 is responsible for the environment
that exists in the browser, right, so we as
developers don't have control over that, our
code gets deployed into all these browsers,
and it has to deal with whatever is there,
right?
It's not like one of our dependencies where
we choose which version it is.
Anything in the browser affects the code runs
and we don't have direct control over it.
TC39 changing things in a way that conflicts
with our code can cause problems.
Why does that conflict even exist in the first
place?
If we were talking about a fairly simple function,
it is quite likely that TC39's definition
would agree with the one the community had
already adopted, and we wouldn't have a problem.
But the thing with the flattened method is
that it is extremely conceptually complicated.
Here's one potential implementation of it.
So, we implement flatten by introducing starting
with an empty list and concatenating the array
together.
The way this works is that it is will combine
any array inside the outer array and flatten
the array to one level deep.
You might decide you want your array flattened
infinitely deep, and this won't do that.
Or you might care about other collections,
like iterable collections like strings, or
a set that is already present in the outer
array — what is the effect of null?
What does it mean to combine these values?
There is a broad set of decisions to be made
here about what this function even means.
And that means there is a broad spates of
different implementations of it.
If you put two implementations of this function
in the same programme, they're likely to disagree
with each other.
And so, one way that you can avoid breaking
things is to avoid using functions that are
this complicated.
Often, if you have something and you want
to flatten is to one level deep, you want
to use FlatMap instead.
If you know your arbitrarily deep, you might
want to use an interpreter.
If you don't know how deeply nested your structure
is, you have a deeper design problem that
needs fixing.
Yes, there is a lot of complexity inherent
in this method which means it's hard to make
it into operate.
We saw a similar thing with the buffer constructor
in node which was taking several different
types of values and giving a different behaviour
depending on the type, and it was easy to
parse a number instead of a string and then
get different behaviour and this caused security
errors in some WebSocket implementations where
you could make the server expose unsanitised
memory to you.
We fixed that by turning into several different
methods that made it explicit, like the user
would make it explicit what behaviour they
wanted: either they want a buffer that contains
the byte data for a string or they want a
buffer that is a fixed size of memory, and
now you've made it unambiguous.
The user is saying what they want.
So it's not just about the return values that
our programmes have, and how things are consuming
them.
There's an implicit contract between any function
and the things it takes in terms of of what
properties it expects them to have.
So, take this contains function.
This takes a list and a value, and it returns
a count of the number of times that value
appears in the list.
It does that by initialising a counter to
zero, and then using a for-of-loop iterating
over the counter.
This works fine with arrays, as you would
expect, but because it uses a for-of loop,
it use any kind of iterable value.
If somebody is using this with a set, it will
only one a 0 or a 1 with the set because sets
only contain one of each value but that is
good to determine truthiness whether something
exists in the set or not.
Say the author of the contains function decides
to change it, their assumption is that it
is only being used with arrays, so they will
use an array method.
They use it using the filter method using
values value to the input, and then return
the length of the result.
So this continues to to work with arrays just
fine.
But now it blows up when you give it a set,
because sets don't implement the filter method.
We get a slightly unobvious error here like
the word "filter" doesn't correspond to anything
the user has said here, it's an error being
thrown by the internals, but the programme
is rejecting an input that it previously accepted
and that is because the author assumed that
people would only use it with one kind of
value, but they never made that explicit.
So, we should also consider side effects when
looking at our programmes.
JavaScript being an imperative language, our
programmes don't just call functions and returns
values, they also have side effects.
For example, here's a function that adds a
dependency to your package.json by reading
the file, parsing it, adding a dependency
and copying back to list.
If we add a console log line, is that breaking
change?
If it is embedded in a programme that expects
to output JSON output, adding this log line
will make that programme fail.
Likewise, if you have an event emitter, you
might decide to add a new value to the data
that is emitted with an event, and JavaScript
lets you call functions with more arguments
than they were expecting, so this ought to
be fine, right?
Turns out somebody is using a vary added function
and expects the values to be the same time
and processed in the same way.
I could go on with these sorts of examples
all day, but the core theme here is that JavaScript
doesn't make it particularly easy for you
to write code that works and keeps working.
It is permissive, works with code that you
expect to throw you an error.
When it gives an error message, it isn't helpful
and doesn't identify which bit of the programme
is incorrect, and you have no way of telling
the compiler how you expect people to use
your programme.
The compiler can't tell you and you've done
something that will break those.
Enough complaining.
What can we actually do?
One popular answer to this problem is semantic
versions, or Sam very for short, which is
that you format your version numbers as three
separate numbers where ink submitting the
front one means you've made an backwards incompatible
change.
Second one is a new feature in a backwards
compatible way, and changing the last number
means you've made a bug fix.
As we've seen, compatibility doesn't hinge
on the module itself but on the context in
which the module is being used.
SemVer has conceptual limitations in that
sense but also practical ones.
It is hard to express fine-grained information.
Like you might have released a breaking change
but you haven't — like all the functions
that I happen to be using from your package
are still fine, so I can't tell from the version
number whether it has saved the upgrade.
— whether it is safe to upgrade.
You can see it playing out in the ecosystem
that a lot of time I've seen breaking changes
in production, they show newspaper bug fixes
releases.
Last year, we had a denial of service vulnerability,
and at the end of 2016, the sdlib library
released since 2009, which gives you an idea
— and that contained a change that meant
previously valid configuration values that
are required by the WebSocket compression
protocol were now illegal and it would throw
errors on them.
In April the following year, Node.js released
4.8.2 and 6.10.2 which bundled this version
of sdlib and broke WebSocket servers.
In August, when we were releasing the new
libraries, we discovered this issue, reported
it to the Node project, and Miles from the
Node project reported this issue to sdlib.
This is not necessarily a bug in sdlib, it
is sdlib's intention that these values are
not legal and you should not use they will.
They didn't know that this would break stuff
to do with the WebSocket protocol.
A month later after figuring out the possible
solutions, the fact that we would have to
deviate from the spec to make the programmes
stop crashing and written everything up, deflate
reels cache, and a month after that Node.js
released versions four, six, and eight in
a paper over the problem.
This gives you some idea of the time it takes
for these changes to propagate through the
system.
Everyone is working with imperfect information
and we have to figure out what is going on,
and that takes time.
When you're changing a system, you don't have
to look at the meaning of the programme like
on its own, you have to think about the effect
on the ecosystem of the community for the
information of that change to spread.
If you make too much change too quickly, you
end up leaving everybody behind and you end
up not upgrading your software.
Another approach to breaking change is try
to never break anything which sound like an
extreme position.
I'm not sure any of us would ever manage to
live by this standard.
But, it is a constraint that people try and
live to.
We saw Ryan yesterday say it's my fault, and
I'm very sorry, unfortunately, it is impossible
to undo now.
This is the world we live in.
Too much stuff depends on our code, and we
can't change it.
It is what I try to live by in my software
and partly to do with how the maintenance
works.
There's two main reasons why I try to work
this way.
The first is I'm not in direct contact with
all of my users.
If I want to change something that's hard
for me to inform the largest is people using
this code that I'm going to change it and
they might need to update something.
Most of the people running my code don't know
they're doing so.
So, my modules are typically embedded as transitive
dependencies inside other things that people
are using, so there are two or three levels
of intermediaries of the end-user and my code,
so, if I break something, there are several
other authors and projects that would have
to paper over that for the end-user to see
any benefit from it.
Because I do a open source in my spare time,
I don't have a predictable amount of bandwidth
for switching problems so it's more valuable
for me to keep things stable rather than release
stuff that might break things and have no
visibility when I might be able to do with
that later.
I take a similar approach to my dependencies.
I leave them open-ended rather than pinning
them with the carat or tilde operator.
I don't want to be a bottleneck on people
getting an upgrade to the things that I'm
depending on.. and I'm taking a risk here
that these things might not be stable, but
that's countered by other measures.
I'm conservative with the things that I depend
on.
I will typically try and adopt something and
live with it for a few months and get an understanding
how it behaves over time before I release
it to my users.
All this hinges on communication.
All of this stuff is — we've seen a lot
of talks at this conference about how we communicate
with each other.
The core message that I want you to take away
from this is that compatibility isn't an objective
technocratic thing about the code itself,
it's about the tact that we all have imperfect
information about the author and the user
and the software know different things about
the software, and that means that the author's
intent and the user's usage will deviate.
The best ways that we can try to avoid things
breaking is by affecting how people use our
software, in how we communicate with them.
We can partly do that through the code that
we write, so, JavaScript is still a small
language but grown a few things recently to
express yourself better.
It might be more appropriate rather than using
a plain array to use a set that might be the
might help you be more specific about your
meaning.
Instead of using a plain old object it might
be appropriate to use a map for the distinctions
we saw earlier.
If you want to think about the operators and
functions that you're using, if you know you're
doing string concatenation, rather than using
the plus operator, which is ambiguous, consider
using templates or the join method which tells
people you know you're doing string concatenation.
You can try as avoid brittle idioms in the
language that make it likely you will have
to change your mind later.
If a programme is growing a long list of parameters,
and you keep adding more things to it, that
makes the callers to those functions a bit
cryptic, like what do true and false and zero
mean?
I don't really know.
Every time you add a new parameter, it gets
more complicated.
A nicer way to do this is object destructuring
and simulating named arguments and you can
give them default values.
That makes the function easier to change and
makes the caller clearer about what it is
doing.
A really good example of this is callback.
If you want to add a new parameter to callback
function, that parameter needs to go before
the callback, and you need to do some mending-up
at the top of your method to account for callers
that aren't passing that new parameter yet.
It is much easier to do this if your function
returns a promise because the parameter list
hasn't been polluted by this extra parameter
that needs to be at the end, so it's much
easier just to add a new parameter there with
a default value and not to have to add any
of that extra stuff.
Think about the error design.
Errors should be a way that help users write
code that works.
They should not be a Carey thing but there
to help people.
Things throwing errors when you're making
a mistake is good for you.
For example, rather than the cryptic error
we saw later about filter not existing when
we parsed in a set, we can put an assertion
on the top of our method that I expect this
to be used with an array.
If not, I will give you a method that tells
you that is what I expected.
So you can spot the bug in this code.
It's probably not very obvious.
The bug is that bytes has be to an integer
but not on a number divisible by eight.
Sometimes, we will parse a fractional value
here.
This worked fine until Node 9.
The crypto-library rounded the number down,
but the programme that was using this it didn't
matter too much because it was asking for
a lot more random data than it really needed,
so the number being rounded down slightly
wasn't a problem.
Then in node 10, we got an error, key element
is out of range.
This error is slightly unhelpful.
The error that the number is not an integer,
not that this that it is out of range, but
crashing a programme that previously worked.
When you're adding errors to a library later
in its life, think about should that error
get to crash the programmes currently using
it?
Is there a better way to communicate that
failure to the user?
It is quite common for people to dig around
in the console and look at the properties
tab to figure out how to use them.
One convention we have in JavaScript is if
you're accessing a lot of things with underscores,
that's a signal that you're doing something
private.
That's not something the language enforces
for you but it's a way that you can signal
to the user I didn't mean for you to use this,
and it will probably break later.
The final thing that we have to rely on is
documentation.
Documentation should help people use the code
in the way that you intended.
Often, people land on Google and even if you
have like really good documentation, arriving
at pros that — prose that requires a lot
of context will give meme more questions than
they arrive with.
I could be going what's a driver object, should
the you shall object be a strict?
How do I put this stuff together?
It would help people to give a self-contained
example and once they understand the basic
concepts, more ready to dive into your API
details and add things in more detail.
And finally, we have testing.
So, testing is a huge topic but I can't possibly
cover in the minute I have remaining, but
one thing that I often see of people advise
with testing that you should not test your
dependencies.
Don't test third-party code.
That's a really good idea.
You can do that.
What it does is validate your assumptions
and tells you where they're no longer true.
Me as the user of the contains function we
saw earlier, I can say it works with sets.
One day when the author changes it, that will
step working, I will get an error, and then
immediately know that the reason my application
is failing is because the dependency no longer
true.
So, what have we learned?
We've learned that compatibility is not pure
a function of the source code but the context
which it's used.
We've learned that context is constructed
by how people use your programme, something
you don't have control over, and finally,
that you can influence that context by how
you communicate with the users, and how you
tell them if the software is supposed to be
used.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]